okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the least common multiple so what
is the least common multiple how do we
find it and then how do we apply it to
some problems as they uh could possibly
appear on the act so first of all let's
take a look at a couple of numbers here
10 and 15. we want to find the least
common multiple so what is a multiple
well multiple is like if you take 10
times 1 it's 10 and 10 times multiply by
2 is 20 and 10 multiplied by 3 see these
are multiples
of 10 right
same thing with 15 15 times 1 or 15
multiplied by 2 15 multiplied by 3 and
so on but the least means the lowest one
that they have in common so in this case
if you look down the list it looks like
30
is the smallest one or the least one
that they have in common now this is one
way to do is to go ahead and list out
multiples of that number the other way
to do it is to do a prime factorization
tree like we did
back with the greatest common factor so
you go ahead and break down the number
okay into its prime factors
and then what you do when you find the
least common multiple ironically is you
actually pick whatever occurs more so
here we have one two
no twos so we're going to take the one
that occurs more one two this one has
one three no threes we take the one that
occurs more
one five one five it's a tie so we just
take one five if we multiply these
together two times three times five
that's 30 which is the same thing we got
here when we did the multiple so we
listed them out like like that so let's
go ahead and do a couple examples go
ahead and pause the video do these on
your own and then you can check them
when we do them together here
so the first one it says find the least
common multiple of 12 30 and 25 so here
they're throwing three numbers at us
same process though we can either list
out the multiples like we did here or we
could do the prime factorization method
i'm just going to do the prime
factorization method
so i'm going to show you that so that's
2 squared times 3 to the first
30 is
let's see that's 6 times 5 which is 2
times 3 so that's
2 to the first 3 to the first and 5 to
the first and then 25 is just 5 times 5
which is five squared so now when we're
taking the lowest common multiple we
take the one that occurs the most we
have two twos one two no twos that means
we need two twos
one three one three no threes it's a tie
for one and then no fives one five two
fives we take the one that occurs the
most okay so now if we multiply these
together we get
four
times three times twenty five four times
twenty five is a hundred times three is
three hundred so three hundred would be
the lowest common multiple now it might
take you a little while to write out all
these numbers uh like we did here and
then to find the lowest one so this is a
can be a little bit quicker method by
using the prime factorization method
okay example number two
and alarm sounds every six seconds and a
dog barks every 10 seconds how many
seconds elapse between times when both
events occur simultaneously at the same
time right so see if you can do this one
on your own and we'll get into it right
here so basically we've got 10 seconds
which is 2 times 5 right and 6 seconds
which is 2 times 3
and if we compare these we can see hmm 2
to the first 2 to the first we take what
occurs most 3 to the first no 3 so we
take one three one five no fives we take
one five if we multiply all these
together we get
30 seconds so that's the next time that
they're going to be barking and the
alarm is going to be ringing at the
exact same moment
so
definitely something you want to
understand for the act the greatest
common factor in this lesson the least
common multiple so go ahead and go over
it again if you need to i'll see you in
the next lesson